coucou tout le monde je voulais vous
parler d'un projet sur lequel je
travaille depuis quelques temps vous
vous doutez qu'en tant qu'artiste femme
belge qui fait de l'humour noir je
reçois évidemment sur mes réseaux pas
mal de messages de haine ou en tout cas
un petit peu taquin du genre on va te
violer à 8 dans une Mazda tout ça et
derrière moi je me suis dit bon est-ce
qu'il y aurait pas moyen que je tire
quelque chose de tout ça alors tout
simplement il menu cette idée un petit
peu folle tous ces messages j'ai décidé
de les revendre bon là vous voyez par
exemple c'est des messages que moi j'ai
reçu mais il y a pas que moi à des
messages de haine de harcèlement il y en
a partout sur internet alors j'ai décidé
de faire quelque chose de toute cette
matière de la Transformer j'ai décidé en
quelque sorte de recycler la connerie
humaine donc j'ai pris tous ces messages
je les ai mis sur des jolis objets des
posters des vêtements je les ai
évidemment bricolé un petit peu mis en
forme avec un joli design pour les
rendre un petit peu plus drôle et
digeste et c'est comme ça qui est né la
marque trash le recyclage de la connerie
humaine et pour que les connards soient
utiles au monde j'ai décidé de reverser
fait partie des bénéfices de trash à un
organisme qui œuvre pour l'environnement
et la planète donc en gros si on pousse
mon concept jusqu'au bout plus il y a
d'enculé plus le monde ira bien je suis
en quelque sorte la Greta Thunberg de la
fils de putri alors on a par exemple des
trucs du genre tu mériterais que je
vienne te piner la face qui a un
commentaire que moi j'ai reçu mais il y
a aussi des trucs plus généraux du genre
salut les fils de qui est somme
toute une petite phrase de courtoisie
bien à propos qu'on peut porter dans un
dîner de famille ou lors d'un contrôle
officiel ça c'est vous qui voyez
évidemment tout est bio conçu en France
dans des matières qui respectent plein
de trucs et tout et tout et vous pouvez
dès maintenant aller sur le site et
réserver les produits que vous voulez
vous allez voir il y a pas mal de choses
en prévente parce que on veut produire
de façon responsable donc si par exemple
vous nous dites je vais prendre un
t-shirt fils de et de poster à la
race ben on produit ça et pas en plus et
là bah vous pouvez les voir sur la page
ta commande de trou duc ah oui parce que
c'est évidemment moi qui est conçu le
site en entier et j'ai tenu dans la
communication à rester fidèle hostile
littéraire des haters voilà je fais des
gros bisous